نعم حتى الان الموضوع يعني مرتبط بجدول لا
يوجد جدول زمني معين انما يتم
اجلاء السكان من هنا تباعا الى مناطق اخرى
لكن حتى نقترب اكثر من المشهد ونكون على
صله مع الاشخاص الموجودين هنا سالتقي عبد
الرزاق وهو لاجئ سوري مقيم هنا في
كان مقيما هنا عند حدوث الزلزال ومنذ
سنوات طويله حسب ما اخبرتني مرحبا عبد
الرزاق اول شيء الحمد لله على السلامه
الله يسلمك انا بس حابب اطمن
فقدته حدا من العائله او يعني ان شاء الله
ما في اضرار اول شيء جسديه قبل ما نحكي
بالاضرار الماديه والله الحمد لله على كل
حال فقدت اختي وابنها وسهري مكسورين من
طرفين ضلو شي 12 14 شهر تحت البناء
الله يرحمهم يعني بصراحه خبر مؤسف الله
يرحمه يعني ونتمنى يعني نكون قلوبنا معكم
حقيقه نتمنى يعني هيك الله يلهمكم الصبر
بس انت عم تقبلني انت انقذتهم كيف قدرت
انقذهم لانه اول ما ساعه اربعه
زلزال خفيف ثاني شيء بلش زلزال كبير طولت
شي اربع دقائق اربع دقائق
اول ما طلعت هل البنايه تحت هاي البنايه
بيجي شي خمسين فيها على الارض نحن جمعنا
بعضنا حالنا وجينا لهون
تغريد اتصلت على السهري ما ردوا علي اتصلت
فيه ما ردوا علي رحنا لهنيك انه شفنا
البيت واقف عليهم
عيطنالهم عيطنا لهم سهري بس كان
عم يحكي
ضلينا شي 14 15 شهر لجبنه جرافتين كبار
لحتى طالعناهم بالزور
اختي كانت متوفيه مباشره ابنه كان متوفي
جبناه على البيت ابنه صار يفتح عينه دغري
اخذناه على المشفى
خمس دقايق بالمشفى
يعني طلعناه من تحت الانقاص كان متوفي
جبناه على البيت فتح عينه دغري اخذناه على
المشفى بسيارتي صحافهن وقفناها
كان عايش واخدنا على المستشفى
وفي عالم كثير هون في عائله راحت منهم 60
واحد عيله واحده
بستين واحد عيله
ومعروفين هون بالنور بيت قناعه معروفين 60
واحد في جماعه تراك بعرفهم اللي بس ابنهم
طلع ساق هاي البنايه ضلو شي ثلاثه ايام
فيها لحتى طلعت مره وحده عايشه منه
كل سكان بنايه بيت جاري هون نزل عليهم
ابنهم توفى
وانقذوه ونطلعوا منهن
يعني حقيقه يعني الباقيه بحياتكم مصائب
الجمله نتمنى لكم الصبر والله يعطيكم
الصحه والقوه بس انا لا حابب تحكي لي عن
وضعك هون بالمخيم حضرتك مقيم او اخدت خيمه
عن جديد حسب ما خبرنا اخدت قيمه امبارح
بالليل
طول نهارين كنا تحت المطر وقاعدين هون
بالشوارع لانه كل العالم كانك بعدين رحنا
في حديقه فوق رحنا اخذنا شهاده الخمس
سكنا فيها ومباراه يجينا لهون المختار
اللي منطقه هون بيقعدوا فيه اخذنا اربع
خيام هون لخمس عيال خبروكن قديش راح تضلوا
قاعدين بالخيام ما خبرونا حسب الوعاده
بجوز ثلاثه اشهر يطول 20 شغله قال بجوز
ثلاثه اشهر فيه مين خبرك هيك مختار
المنطقه هون لا الدوله خبرونا
قال له انه مو مبين بجوز ثلاثه شهور بجوز
اسبوعين بيجوا ثلاثه اسابيع بحسب حتى الان
الوضع غير معروف اسبوع اسبوعين او ممكن
نوصل لحد اقصى ثلاثه شهور
نحن ان شاء الله بنتمنى انه الموضوع يتم
بسرعه لكن بدي اسالك نقطه اخيره ما رح
اطول عليك كيف وضع المساعدات ان شاء الله
مرتاحين ما عم ينقص عليكم شيء لا وضع
صادات منيحه بس في عالم كثير عم تشتكي من
الخيام ما عم يوصلن خيامنا ثلاث ارباع
العالم نايمه بالشارع
اهم شيء خيام في عالم كثير
فعلا هي ازمه حقيقيه موضوع الخيام هذه
السيده ونحن على الهواء مباشره
زلزال وانا قاعده بره والله العظيم اركض
وراهم مثل الكلب الله يعزك ما ودي غير اني
مرضانه معاي السكر
وين كنتوا قاعدين
محلي
فاتح محلات
بيتكم ان شاء الله ما اتاثر
ما هو ممنوع ممنوع اساسا هلا القعده
الخربان بكبيها
اكلنا البرد يعني
ما بنتمنى تعيشوا هذه الظروف يعني حقيقه
يعني الاوضاع صعبه عند الجميع
انا كل الليل عظامي وقع قمت بدي تعتر
وابن اختي
وقع عليهم البيت بنتي جوز بنتي اربعه
دراهم وين برايتهم
والله العظيم
شو بدي اقول لك الباقيه بحياتكم حقيقه
نحن هنا يعني حقيقه عم نحاول عم نحاول
نوصل مساعدات مساعدات
الحمد لله على السلامه الله يسلمك قديش
صار لك هون
يعني بتركيا 12 سنه من اول الحوادث طيب
بيتك تاثر بالزلزال
تكسر كله للبراد التلفزيون كله نزل حاليا
ما عندكم خيمه
لاربع زوجتك
يعني ما في غير اي كلمه ممكن توصف حقيقه
المعاناه اللي انتم موجودين فيها نتمنى
بسرعه يعني وان شاء الله صوتكم يوصل على
عبر شاشه العربيه حتى توصلكم خيمه بشكل
عاجل نحن بصريح صراحه
وين هاي الصاله
مغربي قام المقام
روح شوفه مليانه
من العراق
ناكل مع بتيجي
نفسار
كتير خير الله كثير بس بالنخيمه في نقص
بالخيام بس في معونات كتير في كتير كتير
كتير
بس خيمه
هلا
جينا بالليل بركنا معه
اي والله والله العظيم بس
بس معلش كان بعيد بالتاكيد هناك الكثير من
القصص الماساويه والروايات المؤلمه التي
يمكن ان يرويها
الناجون من هذه الماساه نتمنى بالتاكيد
زيدان ان تصل اصواتهم
للمسؤولين واصحاب القرار
سنكتفي بهذا القدر شكرا لك من منطقه
نورداغ في غازي عنتاب كنت مع العربيه